well first of all I'd say thanks to
Feist carpets I think it's fantastic
that what we're doing is really trying
to motivate I'm so much of the youth and
also social media what we've done that
with and what I've done is the CEO is
really used social media and their ways
to extend out and get to so many more
people the question that I'm really
looking at it answering is those about
what what about Indian CEOs and what
about Indian management by far India has
been and has been for a long time a
darling of the world where much labour
has come from and where lots of
companies have flocked to for additional
skills what we're now seeing is is that
those high level skills are those those
skills that have been used in the Indian
market in fact are being dried up in
fact are being taken away because of the
amount of growth almost ten percent gdp
growth here in india what we now need to
see is the next level which is CEOs and
managers really knowing how to unleash
the potential of individuals within
companies having the ability to really
reduce the amount of turnover and
nutrition that happens within Indian
companies I know our organization in
India is very keen on making sure that
we can train and retain but in order to
do that we have to reduce the turnover
and nutrition which means we have the
better leaders better coaches and better
ways of doing business thanks